il manque véritablement un volet
concernant l'emploi des seniors dans
cette proposition de réforme des
retraites c'est la raison pour laquelle
la Commission souhaitée améliorer le
dispositif notamment en prenant en
compte à la fois les seniors qui sautent
au chômage mais également les seniors en
emploi en ce qui concerne les seniors au
chômage nous proposons un CDI Seigneur
c'est quoi un CDI senior c'est comme un
CDI chantier un contrat pour aller
jusqu'à là fin de carrière du salarié
l'âge du taux plein en contrepartie il y
a une négociation entre l'employeur et
l'employé pour aménager le travail
prendre en compte justement les
différentes préoccupations qui peuvent
être liées à l'âge du salarié pour
inciter l'employeur exonération de la
cotisation famille ce qui permet aux
dispositifs d'être largement utilisé en
ce qui concerne les seniors qui sont
encore en emploi nous avons proposé nous
allons même proposer que la retraite
progressive
débute dès 60 ans c'est une façon de
finir la carrière de façon à ce que le
salarié ne perde pas trop de pouvoir
d'achat continue à travailler n'est pas
forcément à temps plein vous voyez ces
dispositifs incitatifs sont tout à fait
essentiels pour adoucir ce passage de
travail supplémentaire
[Musique]